welcome back raider nation is expanding
the team opened up a brand new raiders
image store in downtown summerlin and
we're giving you a look inside
[Music]
so this weekend is the grand opening of
our downtown summerlin location for the
raider image we have the entire store on
sale which by the way i should mention
never happens typically there are
exclusions so you can get everything
from jerseys t-shirts headwear including
the exclusive product that you can't
find anywhere else one of the things
that we really are excited about is the
fact that we just launched an exclusive
collection called two swords it's a
deconstructed take on the shield
and it comes in different styles that
include raider nation
and headwear t-shirts novelty and it's
something you can only find at the
raider image that's me back in the day i
used to do that
whoa how about that so on opening day we
were fortunate enough to have jay
schroeder here signing autographs for
fans back when i was playing i don't
think anybody ever had a concept that
the raiders would be here we all knew
that al lived here and he loved the
place and everything else so
it's fun for them you know for us to see
them come back and be here
and just
it's more special because the city has
embraced them and that's doing a big
part and you know we got to thank the
golden knights they broke the ice and it
literally broke the ice on that and uh
this is a great sports town and the
regular raiders are fortunate to be here
so on saturday from three to five we
will also have
leo gray
come and sign for our fans the great
thing about the raiders brand is that
obviously we are global our friends our
bands are all over the world however the
opportunity to bring the raider image
closer to them throughout las vegas is
one of the best opportunities right so
to be here in summerlin is amazing we
can't wait to have the fans come and
visit us
when is your birthday february so i have
until february to save seven thousand
five hundred dollars to buy you that
sparkly football yes you know what i'll
take the sparkly hat okay certainly i'm
gonna start small okay you gotta hold up
to it but thanks for thinking of me i
was waiting i was like where's the
sparkle there it is
the grand opening sale is going on until
tuesday july 5th so be sure to check it
out